you may have seen this UFO video
circulating Reddit four months ago this
tiny little dot flying across the frame
captured the attention of 100
000 people in a matter of hours and had
them believing in Aliens
but here's the thing I faked it all a
unique perspective about five minutes in
After Effects and one post the video
took off immediately and I was flying
high but there was one thing I didn't
consider the metadata
and just like that my beautiful UFO got
effed in the O turns out the UFO
Community is really good at spotting
fake so logically there's only one thing
left to do we're gonna try again
wait we yeah like you and me you're
welcome in the video that is mine yeah
ours ours come on
ours
you should be smiling
that's better
[Music]
so if we are to create a truly seamless
fake UFO video yeah first of all I want
to just kind of break down what happened
four months ago uh when I faked this
first video yeah because originally it
was supposed to be a challenge for the
whole crew right we take four of us and
compete to sort of like make the most
viral fake UFO video that we possibly
could yeah we were all very excited
about doing that yeah yeah and we didn't
really get the think of the chance well
I got the chance
it is March 3rd Matt has made the first
official post and that's correct it's
popping off because I was so excited
about it I like really wanted to jump
into it because I had already had a
really convincing plate to use from my
stepdad's plane because he actually
flies planes it's such a unique
perspective and I think it would get
people to click on it the visual effects
aspect to this was actually super simple
because it was just a small little orb
this is the UFO this is the visual
effects shot oh my gosh yeah I remember
actually the first few times that you
showed me the video I didn't even see it
and once I saw it's like oh now I see it
and it almost like you earn it you like
you discover it it's all like every
horror movie that I've ever seen I can't
really think of a time where I was
satisfied seeing the monster after it
had been hidden the entire movie because
my imagination had made it way scarier
than what it ended up being and that's
what yours did so well it was just your
your mind could kind of just pour in and
make it whatever it wanted really the
thing is here though it's not just about
the footage yeah the VFX shot it's
actually the story that you spin around
it and how you post it on Reddit the
presentation is everything right in the
comments once this video is posted we're
peeling back the layers of the story
we're not revealing everything at once
we're not showing all of our cards so
it's basically just adding these little
moments in the comments of like this
Tinder that you're throwing onto the
fire you know that'll ignite uh new
conversations and also like create a
little bit of controversy a little bit
conversation you know and this like this
went proper viral like very quickly yes
we just got another thousand views as we
were talking is it hard to do this to
like fake these videos I mean I would
imagine that the more that people are
watching the more people that are seeing
the more the demand goes up for further
evidence of something you're totally
correct and that's exactly what happened
here they wanted the original video and
I went like I should send them the file
so of course this visual effects file
was exported from After Effects
um but it was saved specifically with
the name and Convention and codec found
on the iPhones the problem is there's
deep rooted metadata in these files that
I was not aware of at all but there's
literally a website called metadata to
go and you could just plug in any file
you want and it extracts literally
everything in the history of the file
UFO footage undeniable evidence it's the
worst thing you can gonna name dot AEP
the one thing you didn't want was a path
to a folder that indicated that we are
VFX artists I just thought maybe if I
said undeniable evidence hey folks OB is
a big fat phone big fat phony wow that
was the hurt it felt bad but also I am
so I can't it's undeniable kudos to
exposing it yeah I mean clearly these
guys it's harder to fool them than you
think it takes a level of detail that I
was unaware of but the thing is I do
want to have a file and a video and a
story that is foolproof I want a UFO
video that truly fakes the internet now
here's the reality the Reddit Squad yeah
they're on high alert yeah they are
they're looking for it now so we're
gonna have to be
A step above
[Music]
okay so there's a lot of UFO sightings
circulating around and it's it's like
picking up steam again you know it's
trending oh UFO performs sharp maneuver
after laser pointer directly hits craft
30 thousand upvote so what's happening
here that's that it's totally a bug
right it's a bug it's 100 a bug it's
just a bug yeah but there are still
questions being raised here and that's
what makes it so popular right it's it's
obscure enough this is interesting this
is sort of a night vision perspective
and then there's this it's a weird one
it's moving irregularly that's something
that we did with the original video too
is change directions unnaturally to an
aircraft that is known right this one is
literally on the news and you're gonna
see how ridiculous that is okay so look
at look at how it starts off talk about
after effects motion work and look at
how fast it goes everyone in the
comments totally knows it's fake as well
you know this is like clearly clearly
fake right what if we learned and keep
it simple don't get cocky with it is it
hard to do this
allow people to fill in the blanks with
their own imagination yes nobody no bugs
no bugs no bugs something that is
clearly moving in a way unknown to man
inorganic right in order so with the VFX
element of this you know we I feel like
I want to elevate it from the first one
if you're not aware uh I snuck my fake
UFO video to a debunking session with
Sam and Nico I love it so which worked
perfectly they didn't know that it was
mine right meaning I could get some like
actual uh feedback from an expertise
great visual effects artist yeah and the
thing is I didn't fool them I think this
is fake I think this is fake too there's
no motion blur on the cockpit as it
jumps from here to here and that little
object should be just as crisp as the
cockpit window somebody tried to trick
us yo let's get up there let's get up
there so with your help I want to make
this bulletproof right and using Sam and
Nico's advice just make sure that the
object in the sky is as realistic as
possible first steps we gotta get that
plate something that is interesting
attention grabbing and also helps tell
our story right yeah I think I know a
man that could help us out
[Music]
Ren you have a Tesla and Teslas are cool
because they have multiple cameras
multiple angles on them you always have
the ability to capture uh what you've
seen I haven't configured so like
whenever I hit the horn it'll
automatically record the previous 10
minutes so basically what you've done
for us here Ren is you've captured like
different angles uh in a more remote
location I had to like literally drive
up into the mountains legendary so I did
that yesterday and I got the footage for
you I have like the front angle the back
angle and then two different side angles
that are also kind of pointed backwards
have you done any Research into Tesla
dash cam metadata yet no but I will my
goal is to make a finished VFX shot that
looks like raw footage straight out the
Tesla so I can redeem myself in this
horrible metadata blunder yeah because
everybody
everybody is making fun of you yeah yeah
behind your back mostly if that helps
Inspire maybe a little bit
we have the plate footage from right now
which is a great start it's everything
we need to lay the foundation of our
deceit really the first thing that I'm
going to do is jump on the 3D tracking
my goal essentially is to track each of
these different cameras and marry them
together so that it's one cohesive body
of three cameras that's moving through
3D space once we have that it's a matter
of actually modeling the UFO which I've
done here and might I say I have a gift
I'm not meaning to brag I just I think
that I'm a fantastic modeler and I think
this is a great Showcase of my skill set
you know we also have our three cameras
here which we can see moving through
space and the important thing there is
now I do One Singular animation of our
UFO object it's consistent timing wise
and perspective wise across all three
cameras so if someone were to take all
this footage and line them up it would
make sense spatially another very
important aspect to this is the motion
blur matching with these Tesla cameras
there's not a lot of motion blur the
unfortunate side of lowering the amount
of motion blur is that you see more
definition of your object and that
really is the
ugly balance of trying to make something
believable here is you need to see
enough of it but man if you see too much
it's really easy to write off so with
all this taken into account it comes
down to the most important part and
that's the composite we need to match
all of those elements the blacks the
whites the compression level inside of
nuke in order to make this believable
because without that this will all fall
apart immediately hey Jordan
Jordan so check this out ready what I
have here is a command window and within
it Matt's real UFO footage undeniable
dude this is how they caught you that's
how they caught me but this is more than
that because what this means is I have
access to it on on the computer on the
Mainframe maybe I can edit it I'm just
copying the original metadata from the
source file and pasting it onto the new
file that it has on VFX I'm basically
Indiana jonesing the video file oh my
gosh so it literally is copying the
exact metadata from the original exactly
who would have guessed that all it took
was the Mainframe well this is great
news yes this is this is this is a
breakthrough now we just need a video
that'll yeah make it worthwhile yeah get
on that buddy gosh all right I'll go
I'll do something now yeah please I'll
contribute now please I guess we gotta
post this tomorrow so good luck yeah all
right
[Music]
all right Jordan Allen today is the day
I'm so nervous I'm like genuinely
nervous yeah so after exporting the
finished VFX shot and cleaning all the
dirty metadata I'm feeling a lot more
confident that we can release this
original footage so I guess the only
thing left to do now
is to upload the damn thing we got to
get this thing out there man this is the
Moment of Truth Jordan Allen it's
terrifying yeah being it is there were
so many steps to get here right just the
VFX shot alone I don't think we've spent
more time on a single simple VFX shot
like this it's a DOT it's one dot two
straight days of just making sure that
if someone were to go in and zoom in on
that single dot there would be no holes
in it there's also the back story you
know and making sure that's airtight
having that extra layer removed you know
all that stuff we learned from the first
video and we're implementing here if
there is one single thing that we
overlooked the entire house of cards
Falls but I think we've done our due
diligence let's send the ship off see if
it floats run it's time dude
oh I'm hitting it I just hit it it's
loading it's too late come on please
okay here we go now there's nothing else
to do but wait
here we are it's an honor to be in your
presence again you two are some of the
greatest debunking Minds in the UFO
Community people look to you for advice
by knowledge based on the knowledge that
you've given us from the last debunking
video and days and days of research
we've created a new UFO found footage
video you've been paying our salaries
while we've been doing this we give you
unidentifiable perfection
that is one hell of a UFO you have there
thank you we have three distinct angles
all capturing the same phenomena that's
a nice one right there
look at you and your HDR emotion blur
this is also one of the most unique
camera sources I've ever seen you know I
want to see what the back of Prius is
catching in the sky and I'm kind of
getting that Vibe now now what we've
done from this point is we posted this
video xxx files x x x a little on the
nose wouldn't you say indeed however I
think so that is a repost account we
actually posted from two different
Reddit accounts the very first original
post is from an account that has a lot
of karma provided by a friend of Matt
who does Landscaping landscaping and one
comment found he's just a Joe schmoe as
they said nothing suspicious here yeah
wow I'm playing the character of a man
that doesn't know how to edit he's just
a guy who got this footage from his aunt
who drives this Tesla so we gave it a
couple of days just with the original
post this is straight from the Tesla
right there's nothing but done to it no
crunchiness specifically to frustrate
people
I got people kind of mad so we had a
secret weapon we had a Fenner who has
been cooking a Reddit account he made
this over a year ago so he reposted it
with all the bells and whistles and this
one has almost 200 000 views wow so this
required two whole accounts yes yeah I
love the social engineering aspect of
this it's almost more interesting than
everything else that's the most
important part there's a there's a
special Pride I took him watching Matt
in his fake account talk to Fenner and
his fake account we were having
conversations in character it was really
something to watch yeah I gotta say I'm
really proud to announce that in none of
the comments were they suspicious that
this was a visual effect shot and maybe
even more important Matt he put the
original files online for people to
download and explore this is true visual
effects this is true illusion creation I
told you guys have your your gimmick
your reveal but you have your pattern
you have your story you created the
whole theater as well The Details Matter
it every single bit of that video
mattered to fool them even even to the
point that we fooled them because we
didn't really even fool them for every
comment that was believing in this found
footage there were comments denying it
still people were still doubting they
want to believe you know and I it's
admirable it really is admirable but you
know not without that bit of like doubt
in their mind which is important because
you can't just believe everything you
see on the internet this is really great
I have a challenge for you guys can't
help but notice
he didn't give us the ultimate test he
didn't have a steep bunker blind see if
you can actually pass the real test make
a new UFO video and make us think it's a
real shot we've learned and we've grown
learned and grown I think we can trick
you hey you guys
you don't want to miss that video
subscribe because I'm not going to know
when it happens and neither will you
I'll just it'll just arrive until next
time guys keep your eyes on the stars
and in your heart
thank you